continue our coverage on the homeless in
our community this summer the county is
going to be releasing just how many are
experiencing homelessness now reporter
Madison Kimbrough spoke with two
Outreach organizations who specialize in
helping the homeless get back on their
feet
with the County's 2023 homeless census
set to be released this summer Outreach
teams across the valley are working hard
to help those that are experiencing
homelessness get off the streets and
into a stable environment it feels good
to come back to the streets where I used
to run a gun back in the day you know I
I walk into the encampments and I give
them an opportunity to have a
conversation with me Alex Cortez and
Darlene cooey making a difference on Las
Vegas streets both recovering addicts
are now helping those who are just like
them find a way out through working with
Vegas stronger treatment facility they
know I'm from the streets just like they
were you know just like they are you
know but you know like I said you know I
try to give some positive to them along
with Vegas stronger's outreach program
there's the city's more team which
stands for multi-agency outreach
resource and engagement Mario Guzman
more team coordinator says their team
Works seven days a week and the areas
they target are always changing the
majority of our of of risen compliances
on the east side
Valley talking about um Bonanza and 28th
Street where like I mentioned though
there's some empty lots out there and
people get comfortable each year the
county issues a homeless census where
they count the sheltered and unsheltered
here's data from 2022 with percentages
of those experiencing homelessness
broken down by sub-populations with over
5 600 people reported as homeless while
both Vegas stronger and the more team
work hand in hand the county has their
own care team that handles a broader
spectrum of areas across Clark County
reporting near Bonanza and Eastern
Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now
now as for those who are homeless and
reported a disabling condition in 2022
the highest percentage were those with
substance abuse with mental illness
coming in second